Hey guys, it's me PEEEEWWWDIIIPIEEE
and it's Friday so you know what that means? ;))
FRADAY WITH POODIPIE
(funny/troll noise)
Switches to LWIAY Intro.
*LWIAY intro*
LWIAY!!
Got your real bamboozle there, didn't you
you thought it was fridays with pewdiepie
LWIAY
YouTube's favorite show that's right. Everybody. LWIAY
👏👏👏👏👏
Where you guys post a meme and I will review them
prediction
Let's see here
outdated memes while commenting at me saying
*high pitch felix* felix all the memes are dead...
Shathefukhhuph
Let's begin everybody I'm excited.
I never understand the fetish of , ehh, whatever her name. What's her name
Ally McBeal
I never understood it. Okay. She's the kind of girl that's like top of the class, everyone loves and that
you secretly want to
Run a lawnmower over. You ever had a girl like that?
Hey look, it's me everybody!
Despacito two - hey, hey, Monica - yeah
We got to do another one. We got to do another one. Wait what pewds merch are in making the news?
What do you guys do? All right what did you steal? Dude, you got to remove the sticker. Don't be that guy
That doesn't remove the sticker. That's a quite hairy 9 year old
What's up, my 9 year olds? How's it going everybody?
Hope you're enjoying this video so far, please join my giveaway where we're giving in the away this.
Completely authentic
All ya gotta do is like and comment 'I love nine-year-olds' and hit that Bell button and you're in hummingbird
HMMMMingbird, that's right. The meme is still going
You clearly spun it the wrong way, by the way, just it's supposed to go in the right direction of the body
You won't twirl the opposite direction
You dummy, meme correction *CLAP CLAP*
Now do it again and do it right.
What a nice weather we're having today
*weird noise*
Stupid mother nature ~errr~ Snap! Yes, this is going in my cringe compliation
We need to do a PewDiePie, another PewDiePie cringe, Gloria Borger retired, but we still have these
Brave journalist. That's right. The Pew News team does have a lot of employees after all we're a very broad
*and also itsskylol*
large news organization when a comeback hits you ten times harder
You finally killed someone, well done to Brad. Last time you played the game, you nearly killed your effing career
gg *super sad and dramatic music rip Brad*
Well, at least I killed someone BaM
India 3.5 million China 4.3
*drinks*
At teh reh teh reh teh ra army of nine-year-olds *good joke 10/10*
All he had to do was put fortnite in the title. He finally understands the algorithm
I found dame tu cosita in fortnite.
Number one on trending!!!
hawow what a weird coincidence out of all my videos, lil tay videos, blew up. Sorry
Sorry for cussing guys. Oops,
I just get really passionate about these things. Like the lil tay videos already has 7.2 million. Where is the trending!?
Where is the trending? It doesn't make any sense. "imitation* We don't pick the trending guys we swear
Yeah, all right
And it's more earr rrapier
All woman are queen if she streams Oh, I didn't see, he wrote streams
She's a, I can't say that word I would never say that word because all woman are a queen
Let's get - this is scare PewDiePie a season 3 intro
oww, wish will never happen
*poodiepie vs jacksepticoy*
sad
Let's make this corn a meme so pewds is disappointed. I'm not disappoint..ted
This is the standard so I don't know what you guys are on about.
Waiting for 63 million subs
Oh ok, someone caught the moment
Hey
Whoa, you got an exact moment. That's dope
Thank you guys so much for
all the 63 million that are clearly all watching, thank you guys to all my 63 million 9 year olds
*sniff*
Really means a lot to have so many 9 year olds watching my channel
It makes me so happy that I have this army of children
I actually like the new PewDiePie more than the old PewDiePie. Well, I like NO pewdiepie
So thank you very much for this garbage. I wonder what I did to enter hell haha
Think the list is a little longer than that ehahaha
Definitely worth it. Alinity, India, Vice
Oh my god
The list is just gonna keep growing. You know, what about Russians? when Pewds calls you a 9 year old
But you turned 10 more than a month ago. That's literally impossible
10 year olds go straight to ali-a, okay
Petition for PewDiePie to make every meme into bonus meme. don't be ridiculous
I wouldn't waste such precious valuable resources for nothing. Okay, fine. You know, what fine. ehaha
Prefer the real Queen I said the real Queen
~perfection~
Aren't you proud Brad? Okay moving on
Nice sign, but can you do this? But can you do tHiSs?
*only 399 everybodeeh*
No no no, how is this one still going, just let it go, guys Jesus Christ
*laughs*
No, I didn't laugh  *did u skrattar or did förlorar?*
Shut up guys, I'll eat my left testicle promise if leafy quits and never uploads a video
I'm serious 100% I'm saying right now. It's not a call-out. I will eat my left testicle
Oh no, Oh no, Ohh hahahah
Isn't it nicer now
Doesn't it feel better now?
It does doesn't it it feels it feels good. I'm not saying it to be mean but it feels better
10 famous people ruined by drugs
So I just saw this tweet on (my ton line? my online? idk man)
it's a maze and I just spent about 20 minutes trying to figure out how to get to the end because I
have honestly nothing better to do with my life at this point *neither do I writing captions for the biggest channel on youtube*  and after like 5 minutes of trying to figure this out
I noticed that there was a bucket here and
Just use the bucket tool and it's gonna become an okay sign. It's gonna become an okay sign I'm not even care
Bucket tool I set it to black and
I clicked on the white space right here. Oh my god. What an absolute genius. How did he figure this out?
I don't know (sike) Oh, oh my god, goddamnit. Snap. This is going in my cringe compilation snap!
This is got snap snap snaps. Oh my god
You guys are actually nine year old. How about that? I didn't realize I thought it was just a joke
Where is he going to come out?
oh okay *HMMMM?* ahehehe
*attention for all headphone user!*
*screaming*
*i warned you*
That's right
We have we have to two types of people watching me nine-year-olds and soy boys everybody. Basically how I'm still able to make videos
After eight flippin' years, heh
PewDiePie, ItsSkyLOL twitch thots everybody. Female twitch streamer showing ass on her stream
Wow, everybody. Did I tell you about ass by the way? It's out game of the year edition
Finally out check it out link in description (get it, it's real good)
Pewdiepie
63 million subscribers. Are these all active users
oF CoUrSe THey ARe
What, what are you - don't be silly of course they are
That's why I get 63 million views on every single one of my upload. Think about it out of the almost 63 million
Yes, some of them are dead
F - U - N
I like how, how confident the title is 100% going to be in the LWIAY
Kind of feel like cutting it out just because of that. Well, I guess I never saw this one
Alright, why did not you show me this film
*that is 'The Bye Bye Man' by the way, you must watch this, this is very gooood*
it's not my fault. When you send her a cute message, I think for Bob and
vagane
but instead you'll get of getting a reply you end up getting featured
in a video everybody the ultimate honor the ultimate pleasure
The Nirvana, that they're all Indians are seeking. You're welcome
By the way, upvote so pewdiepie to explain to us why he suddenly has good video quality
Well, I'm using the the camera I bought in
Japan it's got 4k. So now you see all my pimples and enjoy everybody enjoy  *clap clap clap clap* that was it for this weeks of lwaiy
Hope you guys enjoy watching this one. Thank you guys for all the memes if you want to submit link is in the description
Thank you for leaving like join the giveaway guys. It's a really really really good one. It's-s gonna be great.
I'll see you guys next Friday for the next week of Fridays with PewDiePie~
That's it for me for now *kiss*
Love you guys so much all my nine year old, Kim has eh eh eh add some cheeky music Brad
zoom in on me
you can see all my pores. Please guys. I love you. You mean the world to me
I love all my 9 year olds, you're so special. Now get back to the training field.
An' do 20 push-ups you fatty *kiss* *quietly* brofist
*please why did I write all these captions for an hour*